hi schön dass ihr eingeschaltet habt bei
ZDF heute live vielleicht habt ihr die
Meldung dazu schon gesehen wir sprechen
heute über die Durchsuchung in der
reichsbürgersszene bei denen in
Reutlingen ein Mitglied des
baden-württembergischen sek durch einen
Schuss verletzt worden ist und diese
Durchsuchungen heute die stehen ja auch
im Zusammenhang mit der Razzia am 7
Dezember letzten Jahres bei denen eine
mutmaßliche Reichsbürger Gruppe
aufgedeckt wurde die einen Staatsstreich
geplant haben sollen ja und zu dieser
Tat und der hat ja heute aber auch der
reichsburger Szene generell spreche ich
heute mit unserem Reporter Andreas linke
der ist vor Ort in Reutlingen wir sehen
da schon erste Bilder dann sprechen mit
meinem Kollegen Christoph Schneider aus
der Redaktion Justiz und Recht und zum
Schluss mit dem Rechtsextremismus
Forscher Miro Dietrich aber wie immer
spreche ich nicht nur mit denen sondern
auch mit euch habt ihr Fragen zum Thema
oder wollt eure Meinung loswerden dann
schreibt uns hier im Youtube Chat oder
per E-Mail an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de
jetzt schalten wir aber erstmal zu
unserem Reporter Andreas linke der ist
vor Ort in Reutlingen hallo Andreas
was genau ist da heute in Reutlingen
passiert
also hier hinter mir ist das Wohnhaus im
obersten Stock ist der Verdächtige aus
der reichsbürgerszene dort hat er gelebt
im Moment läuft hier noch die Tatort
Sicherung also man sieht die Polizei ist
noch vor Ort die Spurensicherung ist
noch unterwegs es geht auch um die Frage
wie viel Waffen sind da überhaupt noch
in diese Wohnung es sei wohl eine ganze
Menge auch schwerere Waffen da oben drin
hört man und ja es ging um die Frage
waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis aus in der
Folge auch aus der Razzia vom Dezember
hat man eben herausgefunden naja das ist
einer der in dieser Szene der irgendwie
unterwegs ist der hat eine
waffenrechtliche Erlaubnis und ja die
umzukehren und sagen ja wir müssen mal
schauen darf der überhaupt oder sollte
der überhaupt Waffen haben
das ist der Prozess der gerade läuft und
in diesem Gesamtprozess ist diese Rasse
heute morgen zu sehen heute morgen kam
mir ein Spezialkommando der
baden-württembergischen Polizei hat
diese Wohnung eingedrungen hat die
Wohnung gestürmt und ja auf sie wurde
mit einer schweren Waffe geschossen so
dass seine der Polizisten schon verletzt
ist aber nicht lebensgefährlich das ist
die Situation die heute morgen vor Ort
sich abgespielt hat danach wurde der
Tatverdächtige dann verhaftet
wir haben schon gehört dass der Mann der
da geschossen hat ja eigentlich erstmal
kein Tatverdächtiger war oder was weiß
man denn schon zu diesem Mann explizit
ist er jetzt wegen der versuchten Tötung
also das hat jetzt auf ein Polizisten
geschossen darum geht er jetzt als Tat
für richtige vorher galt er eben im
Bezug der reichsbürgerszene als
Waffenbesitzer und mit einer
waffenrechtlichen Erlaubnis und um die
ging es und um die Frage wie viel Waffen
hat dieser Mensch der auch Sportschütze
ist ähm wie viel Waffen hat er und an
die ranzukommen und eventuell diese
Erlaubnis zu widerrufen und die Waffen
einzusammeln in so einer Art sehr dass
war das Ziel sozusagen die zweite Welle
so hat das eben hier gerade der
Innenminister von Baden-Württemberg
gesagt die zweite Welle nach der ersten
Welle im Dezember im Vorgehen gegen die
Reise
was war ja heute nicht die einzige
Durchsuchung oder also diese ganze
Razzia heute stand ja schon im
Zusammenhang mit der letzten Razzia
kannst du sagen wo da heute noch gesucht
wurde
es sind bundesweit zahlreiche Wohnungen
durchsucht worden ich habe weiß jetzt
nicht genau wo das noch stattgefunden
hat ein Teil hier eben in Reutlingen
gesagt habe es gilt als zweite Welle
nach dem Einsatz vom Dezember als ja 50
Tatverdächtige festgenommen wurden die
auch in Untersuchungshaft sitzen und in
diesem Umfeld hat man eben weiter
gesucht und weiter untersucht wer
eventuell auch zu dieser Szene gehört
und wer Waffen zu Hause hat und darum
ging es eben in dieser zweiten Welle
auch da wieder schnell zuzuschlagen und
in einer bundeseinheitlichen Aktion
gegen diese Waffenbesitzer vorzugehen
du hast gerade schon gesagt der Polizist
oder der SEK-Beamte sei nicht
lebensgefährlich verletzt weiß man schon
wie es geht ist er auf dem Weg ins
Krankenhaus
ist wohl im Krankenhaus genau es wurde
hier noch nicht bekannt gegeben der
Innenminister hat
seinen Respekt vor der Arbeit des
Polizisten und der gesamten Polizei
geäußert und sein Mitgefühl gegenüber
dem verletzten Polizisten
es heißt hier er sei von einer schweren
Waffe getroffen worden was natürlich
dann auch auf die Schwere der Verletzung
schließen lässt aber sie ist eben nicht
lebensbedrohlich
danke Andreas für diese insights erstmal
von vor Ort dankeschön
ja und wie ich schon am Anfang erwähnt
habe diese heutige Razzia die steht ja
im Zusammenhang mit dieser sehr groß
angelegten Anti-Terror Razzia gegen
sogenannte Reichsbürger im Dezember
letzten Jahres vielleicht erinnert ihr
euch noch daran da wurde in Österreich
durchsucht in Italien und in mehreren
Bundesländern in Deutschland damals
wurden 25 Männer und Frauen festgenommen
worden und zu der Verbindung dieser
Razzia und der hat ja heute spreche
jetzt mit meinem Kollegen aus der
Redaktion Recht und Justiz Christoph
Schneider hallo hallo Christoph schön
dass du bei uns im Studio bist wenn ihr
da draußen Fragen an Christoph habt ich
glaube ihr könnt Christoph gerade noch
gar nicht sehen da warten wir noch mal
einen Moment bis wir beide zu sehen sind
hier neben mir steht Christoph genau
jetzt können wir uns beide sehen wenn
ihr da draußen Fragen an Christoph hat
zu dieser Razzia und zu Verbindung
dieser beiden Razzien im reichsbüro dann
schreibt uns gerne im Youtube Chat oder
per Mail Christoph ich würde gerne
zuerst mit dir mal auf einen Tweet
unseres Bundesjustizminister Marco
Buschmann gucken ich mache den hier am
PC mal auf und lese ihn auch einmal vor
falls ihn da draußen nicht seht der
Generalbundesanwalt ließ heute 20
Objekte durchsuchen die Maßnahmen steht
im Zusammenhang mit dem
reichsbürgermilieu dabei wurde ein
Polizist angeschossen das zeigt wie
gefährlich die Einsätze sind die
Waffenbehörden sind verpflichtet
Reichsbürger zu entwaffnen Christoph
kannst du uns erzählen warum nach der
Razzia im Dezember jetzt der General
Bundesanwalt eingeschaltet ist überhaupt
was ist das für ein Vorgehen also der
Generalbundesanwalt war auch schon bei
der Razzia Anfang Dezember eingeschaltet
weil das was die reichsbürgerszene plant
nach den Erkenntnissen der Ermittler
geht es darum dass sie eine sogenannte
staatsgefährdende Straftat begehen
wollten sie haben sie versuchen wollen
die Bundesrepublik zum Umsturz zu
bewegen also unsere verfassungsmäßige
Orten wie wir sie alle kennen zu
durchbrechen und bei solchen Delikten
ist aufgrund der staatsgefährdenden Art
der Bundesanwalt die Bundesanwaltschaft
die Behörde die zuständig ist und in dem
Fall hat er Generalbundesanwalt Peter
Frank die Ermittlung übernommen im
Dezember und es war eine der größten
Durchsuchungsaktion der
Nachkriegsgeschichte überhaupt also es
waren mehrere tausend Beamte im Einsatz
du hast es angesprochen es sind damals
23 Leute innerhalb Deutschlands
festgenommen worden dann noch zwei
weitere im Ausland also insgesamt dann
die 25 Festgenommenen es gibt den Prinz
von Reus der als mutmaßlicher
Drahtzieher dieser
reichsbürgerszene gilt der diesen
Umsturz mit bewegt haben soll es gibt
eine ehemalige Richterin zur Zeit
suspendierte Richterin und
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete Elisabeth
walter-winkelmann und diese Ermittlungen
hat der Generalbundesanwalt bei sich
gefühlt diese Leute sind in
Untersuchungshaft und bei dieser
Durchsuchung bei dieser Razzia sind
umfassende
Beweismittel sichergestellt worden
Computer Festplatten Mobiltelefone aber
auch schriftliche Unterlagen und das
wird jetzt peu à peu ausgewertet also
ist seit der Razzia Anfang Dezember
ausgewertet worden durch das
Bundeskriminalamt das Bundeskriminalamt
ist dem Generalbundesanwalt unterstellt
arbeitet ihnen zu und das
Bundeskriminalamt neben einzelne
Landeskriminalämtern haben Beweismittel
hier ausgewertet und aus diesen
Beweismitteln ergeben sich weitere
folgeermittlungen so dass der
Generalbundesanwalt dann auch jetzt die
heutigen Maßnahmen entsprechend
angeordnet hat kannst du uns denn sagen
welche Erkenntnisse aus dieser letzten
Razzia jetzt ganz konkret zu dieser
Razzia heute geführt haben also was hat
man denn da gelernt was für neue
Indizien gibt es also sie werden diese
ganzen
Dinge die ich schon beschrieben habe
also Mobiltelefone schriftliche
Unterlagen ausgewertet haben und da
werden sich neue Indizien ergeben haben
in die sind die dazu führen dass weitere
Ermittlungen nötig sind und so ist es
dann auch heute zu der Ermittlung gegen
den Mann gekommen in dessen Haus eine
Durchsuchung stattfinden sollte der Mann
wurde nicht als Tatverdächtiger geführt
sondern stand im Zuge dieser Ermittlung
offenbar im Verdacht der Ermittler das
bei ihm sich Beweismittel befinden und
diese Beweismittel die wollten die
Ermittler offenbar heute in Augenschein
nehmen beschlagnahmen mitnehmen und aus
dieser Ermittlung hat sich dann dieser
Schuss ergeben den der nicht
Tatverdächtige dann gegen den
Polizeibeamten
ausgeübt hat ihn verletzt hat und in
Folge dessen ist anschließend dann der
nicht Tatverdächtige als Tatverdächtige
geführt weil er im Verdacht steht ein
Versuch des Tötungsdelikt an dem
Polizeibeamten begangen zu haben so dass
er dann auch festgenommen werden konnte
während wir sprechen gibt's schon neue
Erkenntnisse ich teil die mal kurz mit
euch und aber auch mit dir und zwar da
lässt die Bundesanwaltschaft verlauten
das ist fünf neue Beschuldigte im
Reichsbürger Million gibt nach der
Großrazzia Anfang Dezember gibt es jetzt
heute nach Angaben der
Bundesanwaltschaft 5 weitere
Beschuldigte durch die Durchsuchungen am
Mittwoch in Bayern Niedersachsen und der
Schweiz und auch die sind
verdächtigt auf Unterstützung einer
terroristischen Vereinigung daneben
wurden die Räumlichkeiten von 14
weiteren Personen durchsucht die nicht
als verdächtig gelten das ist dann
ebenso auch diese Wohnung des ehemals
nicht Tatverdächtigen über die wir
gerade gesprochen haben wir haben schon
eine Frage aus der Community an dich und
zwar fragt einen anonymer Frage weiß man
schon etwas über die Verhafteten auch
wieder Richter oder Anwälte dabei oder
ist das gerade noch völlig unklar das
ist doch völlig unklar also da sitzen
wir genauso wie auch alle Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer darauf dass der
Generalbundesanwalt möglicherweise im
Laufe dieses Tages noch eine
Presseerklärung bekannt gibt in denen
sich weitere Hinweise finden zu dem was
da heute passiert es offiziell gibt es
dieses Pressestatement aus der
Bundesanwaltschaft noch nicht wir hoffen
dass das im Laufe des Tages noch kommt
und dann wird sich ergeben was
möglicherweise heute dann auch an den
Ermittlungen sich eigentlich
durchgeführt hat und wie dann damit
umgegangen wird du hast es ja gerade
schon angesprochen diese Razzia im
Dezember war eine der größten Razzien in
Deutschland der Nachkriegszeit was hat
sich denn da für eine Dimension
aufgemacht wie erstaunt war man damals
über diese Dimension die sich da
geöffnet hat und vielleicht heute noch
weiter vergrößert hat
die Dimension war schon enorm und zwar
deswegen enorm weil eben nicht nur mit
mehreren tausend Beamten gegen diese
Szene vorgegangen worden ist sondern man
hat das ja bisher so ein bisschen eher
abgetan und gesagt na ja
reichsbürgerszene
das sind so ein paar ich sag's jetzt mal
ganz salopp Spinner die sich da bewegen
und die eigentlich keiner weitere
Beachtung finden aber das was die
Ermittlung ergeben haben ist dass es
also weit mehr als nur einige wenige
Spinner sind sondern der
Generalbundesanwalt hat im vergangenen
Monat dazu noch mal im Interview
Stellung genommen und gesagt ähm es gibt
die reichsbürgerszene umfasst nach den
Erkenntnissen die die Bundesanwaltschaft
hat ungefähr 23.000 Menschen in
Deutschland und diese Menschen das ist
der Unterschied zu anderen die äußern
das nicht nur in Wort und Schrift und
geben das einfach bekannt was Sie für
eine Meinung haben sondern seien auch zu
aktiver gewaltbereit also man hat bei
diesen Durchsuchungen damals auch
festgestellt
und beschlagnahmt militärische
Ausrüstung Dolche Schwerter
Satellitentelefone Schutzwesten Helme
Uniformen also da sind das sind solche
Devotionalien bei denen man denkt na
vielleicht hat noch der ein oder andere
Nostalgiker das von der Oma irgendwo auf
dem Speicher stehen aber das sind Leute
die ganz klar damit umgehen die
bundesrepublikanische Ordnung aufzuheben
und ganz straff zu organisieren und das
führt dazu dass Leute am Ende dann sagen
da muss man mit aller ermittlungsgewalt
drauf schauen und deswegen ist es auch
gut dass nicht einzelne
Staatsanwaltschaften ermitteln nicht
einzelne Staatsanwaltschaften der Länder
sondern wirklich der Generalbundesanwalt
als oberste Ermittlungsbehörde hier in
Deutschland
wir haben ja auch gerade noch mal die
Meldung dass mehr als 20 Objekte in acht
Bundesländern und der Schweiz durchsucht
werden also wieder eine Gracia die nicht
nur in in Deutschland stattfindet
sondern auch über die Grenzen von
Deutschland hinaus habe ich dich jetzt
richtig verstanden man schließt also von
dem was man da findet auch an Waffen an
verteidigungsmaterial darauf dass diese
Vereinigung staatsgefährdend sein könnte
oder geht es da auch um Rhetorik die die
nutzen um geheime Chats nein ich glaube
die Ermittler gehen wirklich davon aus
und das sind die Erkenntnisse die wir
auch bisher haben das gesagt wird die
diese Gruppe ist weitaus größer als man
das bisher angenommen hat und die sind
eben bereit auch Waffen einzusetzen in
der Szene und sollen das entsprechend
dann auch wirklich versuchen so
umzusetzen dass die
bundesrepublikanische Ordnung zerstört
wird wir haben noch eine Frage an dich
was droht in den Tätern jetzt für eine
Konsequenz
den Tätern droht auf jeden Fall der
Anklage also ganz konkret und wegen der
schweren staatsgefährdenden Straftat und
das ist ein Strafraum der schon im
oberen Bereich angesiedelt ist und das
werden jetzt einfach auch die weiteren
Ermittlungen zeigen aber auch jetzt
nehmen wir den heute dann
Tatverdächtigen weil er auf einen
Polizeibeamten geschossen haben soll das
ist versuchter Mord und das kann mit
lebenslanger Freiheitsstrafe bestraft
werden
ja wir bleiben auf jeden Fall da weiter
für euch dran danke Christoph dass du
bei uns im Studio warst danke schön
wir gucken jetzt noch mal genauer auf
diese reichsbürgersszene das ist ja eine
Szene die in den letzten Jahren immer
mehr in die Öffentlichkeit gerückt ist
vielleicht auch anfangs noch so ein
bisschen belächelt wurde aber ihr fragt
euch vielleicht auch gerade noch mal wer
sind die was wollen die was verfolgt
diese Szene diese Gruppierung für Ziele
die sich zunehmend gewaltbereit zeigt
und das hat sich Antoine kuscheln für
uns angeguckt
Razzia 2016 im bayerischen Georgs Gemünd
ein Spezial Einsatzkommando will die
Waffen eines reichsbürgers sicherstellen
der feuert auf die Polizisten ein
Beamter stirbt wenig später im
Krankenhaus die sogenannten Reichsbürger
haben sich immer mehr radikalisiert der
Verfassungsschutz zählt etwa 21000
Reichsbürger darunter sein und 2100
gewaltbereit ihr Ziel die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland abschaffen einige behaupten
dass das deutsche Kaiserreich
fortbestehe und dessen Verfassung
weiterhin gültig sei mit Berufung auf
diese Reichsverfassung fordern Sie den
Urenkel des 1918 abgedanken Kaisers
Wilhelm II als deutschen Kaiser
einzusetzen
meistens ist es dann doch so dass dann
eben antisemitische Töne Deutsch
schlagen dann sind es die Rothschilds
beispielsweise die im Hintergrund die
Fäden ziehen würden das ist ja
offensichtlich auch bei dem einem
Adligen der jetzt mit als mädelsführer
verhaftet worden ist auch bekannt
geworden dass er offensichtlich der
Meinung ist das ist eine
jüdisch-deutsche juristische
Weltverschwörung geben könnte und das
erinnert natürlich an bittere harte
antisemitische Argumentation und sie
sind immer mehr geworden in den letzten
Jahren unter ihnen auch
Verschwörungstheoretiker der
corona-pandemie das macht sie aber
eigentlich umso gefährlicher weil die
Leute eben noch weniger denken das ist
eine politische Lösung für sie gibt
sondern dass eben jetzt genau die
radikalen Leute die sich verschärft
haben in ihren Positionen denken jetzt
müsste das gewaltsam gelöst werden
Reichsbürger weigern sich Steuern zu
zahlen drucken eigene Pässe und
Geldscheine das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz stuft sie als Staats-
ja und über die reichsbürgerszene und
genau diese Ziele die wieder gerade
gesehen haben über die spreche ich jetzt
mit einem Mann die gerade auch schon im
Beitrag gesehen hat nämlich mit Miro
Dietrich der mir zugeschaltet hallo
guten Tag
ja du warnst immer wieder vor einer
Radikalisierung dieser Szene heute ist
jetzt ein sek-beamter durch einen Schuss
verletzt worden wie hoch ist denn
aktuell die Gewaltbereitschaft
ne Gewaltbereitschaft ist auf jeden Fall
relativ hoch das sehen wir daran dass
zu Beginn der Pandemie sehr viele Leute
aus diesem verschwörungsideologischen
Milieu dachten dass jetzt der große
Umschluss kommen würde also es war eine
große Begeisterung man dachte das Volk
würde jetzt erwachen das hat sich jetzt
relativ getrübt weil man gesehen hat
dass ich eben doch die Sachen nicht
verändern die sind Menschen und vor
allem die neuen die jetzt hinzugekommen
sind wo auch die Querdenken zu
beigetragen hat von den Bühnen wurden
auch reichsburger Erzählungen verbreitet
ähm die glauben jetzt dass sie
tatsächlich einen Feind hätten ähm eine
allmächtige Verschwörung die die Welt
kontrollieren werde dabei werden die
Menschen immer aufgeladen als das
personifizierte Böse also da geht's dann
um Kindern würde etwas angetan dass
diese Welt Verschwörung wird verbunden
mit einer externen Bedrohung eben es
sollte eine Auslöschung der deutschen
Stadt finden durch die Impfung oder eben
das Kinderblut durch Folter extrahiert
werden sollte und diese Menschen denken
eben jetzt
wo sie keinen keinen Rückhalt mehr sehen
dass in dieser Bedrohungssituation sie
ja doch reagieren müssen sie sprechen
viel von einem Krieg in dem Sie sich
befinden und dort ist Gewalt dann eben
legitim also wir sind so am Ende dieser
Radikalisierung Spirale die diese
Pandemie ausgelöst haben
na das ist spannend was du da erzählt
wenn ihr Fragen habt dann schreibt ihr
uns gerne hier direkt im Youtube Chat
oder per Mail an ZDF heute- live zdf.de
dann können wir die hier gleich mit euch
und für euch besprechen wie willst du
denn aktuell die Szene und ihren ähm
Aufbau beschreiben also wie organisiert
sind die gerade wir haben ja da im
Dezember schon gesehen offensichtlich
organisierter als die
Sicherheitsbehörden bisher angenommen
haben
ja die Sicherheitsbehörden das Thema
leider sehr lange verschlafen was dazu
geführt hat dass sie tatsächlich sehr
groß war werden konnten tatsächlich ist
es keine einheitliche Bewegung sondern
es handelt sich hier eher um eine
Ansammlung unterschiedliche Erzählungen
die von unterschiedlichen Menschen
unterschiedlich stark geglaubt wird also
man kann da sehr viel eigenen
Interpretation haben viele dieser
Gruppen sind auch untereinander im
Streit die Zahlen die wir von
Sicherheitsbehörden haben wenn ich als
deutlich zu gering einschätzen wenn ich
mir im digitalen Raum anschaue wie groß
dort Gruppen sind die nee ist um das
Thema geht sind die deutlich größer als
das hier etwas vom Verfassungsschutz
behauptet wird
ja du beantwortest schon so ein bisschen
meine Anschlussfrage wie beurteilst du
das bisherige Handeln der Behörden du
sagst das ist zum Teil ignoriert worden
da ist zum wenig zu wenig passiert hier
fragt auch gerade jemand aus der
Community und zwar super Luigi 73 wie
stark sind denn eigentlich Reichsbürger
in den Sicherheitsbehörden vertreten
also zu Reichsbürger und
Sicherheitsbehörden wissen wir nicht so
viel es gibt eins der Fälle es ist ja
doch sehr widersprüchlich dann doch für
das System zu arbeiten dass ein
Legitimität man eigentlich abstreitet
das heißt es passiert nicht so viel
vielleicht bisschen um das Ganze
einzuordnen wir hatten jetzt heute
wieder bei einer Hausdurchsuchung groß
und Waffen gehen ähm Schüsse auf einen
Polizisten das ist nicht das erste Mal
in Beitrag hat mir das schon gehört der
morte 2016 georgsmünster stattgefunden
hat aber es gibt dann doch viele andere
Fälle erst letzten Dezember gab es bei
so einer rational Reichsbürger hat die
Person mit einer vollautomatischen
Kriegswaffe auf die Polizisten
geschossen dabei wurden mehrere verletzt
ein Polizist schwer im September 2021
ähm deine razziale Reichsbürger hat der
mit einer Armbrust auf die Polizei
geschossen und 2016 gab es auch noch
einen Fall in Sachsen-Anhalt wo auch
Gerichtsvollzieher geschossen wurde und
ich glaube hier sieht man was ich gerade
in dem Fall von Gerichtsvollzieher
anschaut die haben schon sehr sehr lange
mit diesen Problemen zu begrenzen das
BKA hat sich das Thema aber erst
angenommen als 2016 dann ein Polizist
erschossen wurde und auch heute wenn ich
mit Polizisten was von Polizisten in
Ausbildung höre ist dass das Thema
Reichsbürger keine Rolle in ihrer
Ausbildung spielt und das finde ich dann
doch bedenklich wenn wir derzeit zwei
Verfahren laufen haben gegen reichburger
Gruppen wegen Bildung einer
touristischen Vereinigung und eine
Anklage ja veröffentlicht wurde daneben
dieser Gruppe um dies jetzt geht gab es
noch einen verletzten Jahr wo es auch
immer dieses geplanten systemsturz gehen
unter anderem sollte Lauterbach entführt
werden
und ähm im Februar diesen Jahres hatten
wir jetzt eine weitere Verhaftung von
einer Gruppe die auf dem
reichsbürgerinnen zugeordnet wird die
Infrastruktur angreifen wollte der
Stromnetzwerk haben wollte weil sie
dachten dass andere Gruppen dann
Deutschland übernehmen würden
ja das ist echt ziemlich bedenklich was
für uns da erzählst du hast doch gerade
schon gesagt dieses spezielle Thema
spielt zurzeit keine große Rolle oder
keine Rolle in der Polizei Ausbildung
jetzt frage ich mich wie ist denn
aktuell die Beobachtung im Netz also im
Internet wie hoch ist da der
Verfolgungsdruck und wird da genug getan
also Reichsbürger können sich sehr frei
im Internet ausbreiten muss ich sagen
sehr viele diese Äußerungen die
reichsbürgertreffen sind nicht strafbar
wir sehen aber doch das aus diesem
Milieu einen
rechtshilkustische Bedrohungen
entstanden ist hier würde ich mir auf
jeden Fall mehr Beobachtung der
Sicherheitsbehörden wünschen und es ist
natürlich jetzt ein Problem jetzt muss
man mehr tun aber wichtig wäre natürlich
gewesen wenn man irgendwie auf die
Erkenntnisse der Jahre zuvor gehört
hätte und jetzt nicht durch diese
Radikalisierung und durch noch mal das
wachsende Szene in der Pandemie so
überrascht gewesen wäre und jetzt darauf
nicht vorbereitet ist
Thema Strafbarkeit gefragt gerade jemand
aus der Community warum können die denn
eigentlich immer noch reichsflaggen
öffentlich zeigen wann wird das verboten
es ist natürlich viel ein Weg jemand
geht dass man irgendwie jetzt Symbole zu
verbieten viel eine Ideologie ändert das
ja nicht dieser Menschen
hier fragt noch jemand würde den einen
afd-verbot helfen
wir haben zwar erlebt dass gerade auch
bei der aktuellen Gruppe wir
Verbindungen in die AFD sehen aber ich
glaube die Frage ob ein AFD verputzt
sinnvoll ist oder nicht ist nicht mit
dem komplett Freiburger zu machen
du hast uns ja gerade schon erzählt dass
ich unter diesem Oberbegriff
Reichsbürger eigentlich mehrere Gruppen
versammeln kannst du uns dann noch mal
in Überblick geben was für Gruppen das
ganz genau sind und welche gemeinsamen
Ziele die anstreben
also der Begriff Reichsbürger ist
eigentlich auch ein bisschen untreffend
weil es geht eigentlich um ein größeres
Phänomen es geht um den
verschwörungsideologischen souveränismus
waren eben Reichsbürger oder
Selbstverwalter drunter findet es gibt
dort sehr unterschiedliche
Interpretationen ein tut sie die Idee
Deutschland wäre kein souveräner Staat
und dann geht's eben sehr in
unterschiedliche Interpretation wenn man
ein Kaiserreich zurück ähm wo genau war
der Zeitpunkt wo Deutschland zuletzt zu
bringen gewesen sei wie genau will man
da rauskommen
im so eher tun sondern Spektrum ist
natürlich die Idee als ähm Trump
Präsident war war man natürlich
irgendwie sehr froh wenn man von
Deutschland von der Amerika besetzt weil
wenn man ja quasi unter der Herrschaft
von Trump was natürlich sehr viel aus
der mir gut fanden es gibt dort sehr
viele kleine Gruppen nicht alle haben
das Interesse den deutschen Staat zu
stört stürzen und ähm wenn ein neues
ihrer Meinung nach souveränes
Deutschland aufzubauen sondern viele
rufen dann eher ihr eigenes kleines
Königreich aus indem sie Autonomie haben
wollen
du hast jetzt schon diesen Aspekt der
Souveränität angesprochen und hier fragt
Thomas K aus der Community gibt es den
parallelen oder Unterschiede zwischen
den reichsbürgern und den sogenannten
souverän citizens in anderen Ländern
genau Reichsbürger sind quasi die
deutsche Spezialität von Celle sehen wir
ja in sehr vielen unterschiedlichen
Ländern in den USA es ist ein großes
Problem dort haben wir auch öfter Waffen
Auseinandersetzung mit Waffen in den USA
ist die Chef auch sehr nah mit der
Bewegung und auch in Deutschland sehen
wir hier eine sehr große Überschneidung
gerade bei der Gruppe der pathologischen
Union und dieses Jahr bei dieser Rasse
jetzt auch gehen da sah man das der
Verschwörung Glaube an
reichsbürgerzählungen sehr oft sehr
deckungsgleich war bei diesen Personen
jetzt haben wir heute gesehen die
Reichsbürger die verschiedenen Gruppen
innerhalb der Reichsbürger scheinen
gewaltbereit zu sein ein sek-beamter
wurde angeschossen und verletzt und laut
deiner Forschung gibt es ja verschiedene
Phasen der Radikalisierung was würdest
du sagen wo stehen die Reichsbürger der
aktuell in Deutschland und was sind
jetzt so die Perspektiven für die
nächsten Wochen und Monate
wir stehen auf jeden Fall eine Ende
dieser Radikalisierung also nach diesem
großen Wachstumsphase wo sie eben
dachten jetzt ändert sich alles jetzt
gäbe es den großen Volksaufstand der
nicht eingetreten ist sind sie sehr
frustriert und der harte Kern dieser
Leute die eben tatsächlich an diese
externe Bedrohung glaubte denke der Teil
seiner kollektiven warenvorstellung ist
denkt sie müsste jetzt gewaltvoll
Handeln
weitergehen wird das dass wir
wahrscheinlich mehr dieser Gruppen sehen
würden wenn das Milieu jetzt besser von
Sicherheitsbehörden im Blick ist wenn
die Gefahr jetzt mehr erkannt wird dann
würden ihn auch auffallen ups da gibt's
ja doch schon mehrere Gruppen gegen die
wann man das machen sollte
mehr sehen wie viele Leute diese
Erzählungen glauben und viele Leute dort
auch gewaltvoll Inhalte verbreiten
glaube ich nicht dass das jetzt die
letzte Gruppe war die mit der sich die
Sicherheitsbehörden beschäftigen werden
ja wir hören das ist auf jeden Fall ein
Problem was uns wahrscheinlich noch
weiter beschäftigt vielen Dank für deine
Antworten
und ich denke wir bei ZDF heute live wir
bleiben da weiter für euch dran wenn
euch dieses Thema der
reichsbürgerbewegung noch mehr
interessiert als wir das jetzt hier
abgedeckt haben dann guckt unbedingt mal
in der Kontext Folge dazu könnt ihr
einfach bei Youtube eingeben Kontext
Reichsbürger Bewegung mit meinem
Kollegen Theo ansonsten bleiben wir da
für euch dran ich bedanke mich für eure
Fragen und bis zum nächsten Mal